hello everybody and welcome to the
fourth practical full last with Python
tutorial video in this video we're going
to continue working on our homepage so
before we get too much further I just
want to talk a little bit about my
methodology for making a website so a
lot of times at least in the past to
make a website you needed web developer
and a web designer and sometimes a
graphics designer but a lot of times
graphics and web design kind of went
right together so you have to consider
that that there used to be like two
different people right the designer
would hand stuff to the developer and
the developer would actually make the
design happen you know in the code if
you're coding a website yourself you've
you'll find that you're actually you
know it's just you all right and so you
have to kind of think you know what what
kind of order are you gonna do things in
for me I generally like to do it the
same way that you know if you think
about it in the past too
the web designer first designed what
they wanted it to look like you approved
it and you would give it to the web
developer and if you were the web
developer that was the order you did it
and this is no different so we're using
a tear we're using bootstrap to do a lot
of the web designers tasks but in the
end we're still the web designer so we
had kind of have to have it in our head
how we want things to work first and
then you know maybe put them down on a
web site make sure it works and then
after that we build the logic so the way
I tend to do things is first I'll just
hard code it right into the HTML and if
I'm happy with it then I'll begin to use
you know variables and logic and I can't
even write a variable here there we go
variables in logic and dynamic content
I'll add that I'll go to the pipe in it
dot PI file or whatever PI is driving it
and then I'll make my changes pass
through the logic and all of that so
that's my methodology for building the
websites so with Python programming net
first of all the home page is really
important the home page is like the most
important place of your website that is
the landing page for most people so most
people are that's the first page they
see of your website and more importantly
that's where people make the decision
stay or leave and so you want them to
make the decision to stay generally
about you know 50% is is the tipping
point for a good website so if more than
50% of your visitors stick around that's
good if less than 50% of your visitors
stick around that's kind of heading to
bad
I believe the web you know the world
average of website bounce rate is like
60% and by bounce rate I mean that's the
amount of people that visit a website
and get out and leave on the same page
they visited and so bounce rate is a
rate of how many people came to the
website and left so 60% means 60% of
your viewers liked viewed the page and
we're like not really like this website
and I got out so it's it's definitely a
discouraging number when you see it but
it's pretty pretty common anyway that's
my methodology the homepage is important
let's do it so to get started the first
thing you'll want to do is you want to
acquaint yourself with bootstraps so
let's zoom out here we room to weigh in
like that we already have bootstrap but
the bootstrap website like I've been
trying to kind of show you guys is you
know how a real developer actually
develops is not really in their head
that they know everything it's not true
people ask me all the time like how do
you remember all this stuff I don't I
really don't I come to my own website a
lot and I look at the codes that I need
I don't really visit basics anymore but
if I want to know how to make a GUI I'll
revisit my GUI stuff I want to make
flasks I don't remember all those
commands to run or anything or how to
set up flask I just go back to my code
that I've already written and every
developer I know that's the path that
they usually take obviously I do know a
lot of stuff by by memory I can type a
lot of stuff by memory and I can make a
program by memory but generally the
quickest way for me to develop is is to
visit my own previous code and do it do
it that way and then whenever people use
say you know a lot of developers use
JavaScript I know very few developers
that actually know JavaScript they know
how to read it and understand what's
happening but they don't actually write
their own JavaScript I don't know
anybody
actually that writes their own
JavaScript the judge you just copy/paste
manipulate kind of that's it
so anyway moving along that's kind of
the whole point of get bootstrap is you
copy/paste and manipulate and that's why
a lot of people like it luckily I can at
least explain to you what's happening
and all that but I would never write my
hand write my own bootstrap and I don't
expect anyone else to and any developer
who suggests that you do handwrite
bootstrap is just lying to you that's
not how people do it
so anyways coming here you'll want to
kind of acquaint yourself we're not
going to do it in this video I've
already done it I expect you do this on
your own time but get started we've
already done but just I'm holding
control clicking CSS components
JavaScript you can click on customize to
but we're not going to really get too
far into that I don't know bootstrap
loads really slow sometimes I'd love to
know who they're I think they use like
you know content delivery service or CDN
it content delivery network yet and for
whatever reason it takes ever sometimes
I'm tracking a video here bootstrap
let's do it okay so CSS kind of look at
all this stuff this is are basically all
the things that are contained within
bootstrap they've already written CSS
for you to do so the doctype we needed
that we already use that mobile stuff
mobile first that's this viewport stuff
that we wrote already and I kind of
already explained that you can do this
and that will disable zooming in I don't
know why you really want to do that but
you can anyway moving on um here's just
some examples of stacking some content
trying to find something more
interesting this it's more like you know
organization on your website but you can
play with that we're not really going to
touch much of that this is typography
stuff that you don't really you should
already know what h1 and h2 and all that
these are alignment classes basically
all the stuff that's contained within
bootstrap this gets a little more
interesting with their tables so this
normally when you make a table it's just
like a grid that has no lines you have
to you know add your own style bootstrap
sort of done it table table table hover
table whoa
more stuff here Bubble Bobble blah blah
blah forms normally forms look ugly as
hell these forms look nice pretty blue
outline very nice continue scrolling
just a bunch of stuff right it's a huge
page buttons this kind of stuff will be
using that and actually this should look
pretty familiar to you if you're used to
my website this stuff here basically
it's all bootstrap everything is
bootstrap these progress bars bootstrap
the buttons bootstrap in this little
logo looking thing bootstrap bootstrap
bootstrap everything bootstrap these
tabs you guessed it
bootstrap okay it's all bootstrap anyway
so look through CSS learn see what's
available to you so you can kind of know
how to piece together components same
thing these are what those little
symbols came from they're glyph icons
coming down just a ton of components
drop-down menus stuff like that and
these are everything below it is all the
sample code for everything like buttons
drop-down menus everything just has
sample code so you just copy/paste then
your JavaScript for fancy stuff like for
example this is some JavaScript here
where we click on this button and it
Scrolls us down JavaScript did I write
it no a copy and paste it did okay so
anyways coming back over here let's work
on our on our tutorial so just looking
at our website you kind of know okay
well we want a logo here button some
more stuff here a video embedded here
and maybe a button down here I think I'm
willing to skip the breath on editor
this is an editor written in breath on
which is a replacement for JavaScript so
it's a Python editor runs Python code
some code some stuff it doesn't run so
you can't hack my web site by using this
um and it's pretty cool you can check
out their websites there's a link to it
down here for writing JavaScript and
Python maybe soon I'll have a tutorial
on breath on maybe it'll make me write
my own JavaScript once and for all
although I wouldn't really be JavaScript
but my replacement for it anyways back
to ash
toriel here and this is what we were
going to start with anyways so how do we
do it and so first we know we want to
make a button we don't know how to make
a button but we want to we need this
logo how do we get this logo well we can
just right click it copy image URL
let's visit that image here it is
excuse the crack anyway let's click and
drag that one we'll come over to here a
flass cap whoops go into flask app
static we don't have an images directory
yet so let's go ahead and make that new
I'll call it images and I'm going to
click and drag that image into images so
again if if you need any of these image
logos or whatever feel free to use your
own logo as well it's totally fine
you can change all this stuff if you
want but if you need the logo here it is
Python program Nannette slash static
images main logo dot PNG all the stuff
should be available to you because you
can just go to the website so we've got
that and now let's go ahead and get
started so in my example was showing you
paragraph tags we wrote the paragraph
tags actually under the HTML tag don't
really want to do that so generally what
I do is make a ton of space or at least
a lot of space and just kind of forget
about the HTML tag you don't want to put
anything below it so just do that so now
we're ready to build the header of our
website and this is the traditional idea
of a header the header is generally what
houses your navbar and your logins and
stuff like that and in the past you had
a header file and you would include the
header file at the top then you had a
footer file and you would include the
flitter file bottom and it made it
really easy for whenever you made a new
page you didn't have to recode the
header because then god forbid you
decide to change your navbar oh my gosh
now you got to go through all those HTML
files so anyway nowadays things are a
little different if you use this at
least this paradigm that we're using
here so first we want to have this nav
bar so we can come here and be in
components let's just ctrl F for nav bar
uh so let's here's our default navbar
we'll come down here and we can see okay
we've got this navbar basically we could
take like all of this code for example
but let's just take the entire thing the
entire source code they've given us like
this and actually we want the brand
image well we'll take this entire code
though just to show you so we'll copy
that navbar code paste save we edited
HTML we have to restart Apache now
refresh and here we have a nav bar now
the drop down
yeah the drop down won't work because we
haven't included the Java Script but
that's okay well we'll talk about it
later but anyway the links work we can
hover and stuff and so the nav bar you
know works we could type stuff here we
could hit submit it doesn't link to
anything but we could do it if we want
to and again we didn't have to like do
any of the CSS for this we just copy and
paste it uh so anyway we're gonna close
this though mm-hmm and we're gonna look
for let's go over here let me do a nav
let's see now bar whoops now our header
and we are looking for nav bar brand let
me look through our brand so we
basically want like this code here um
but well I'm gonna do I think we'll
actually end up typing our own pretty
much but we can take the nav bar let's
see this right here let's just take this
all the way to this I think we can get
away with that I think that's a full div
to tip to check your tags in a notepad
plus plus you can highlight and write so
everything has been closed off you just
always want to make sure everything
closes off so again like button here's
the initial button here's the closing
off of the button okay so you just want
to make sure that that's occurring and
it is for us so we can save that let's
come over here refresh and now we just
have the brand here and we don't need
this toggle navigation stuff so I can
rid of that if you wanted but actually
we're not even going to use the button
so I'm just going to do this this our
navbar header delete the button stuff
and then you have a class navbar and and
the href will say is basically at your
home so you just put a slash there we
don't really need any any text or
anything like that
within it but then we are going to add
an image so a is the way of creating a
link basically so anything we put in
here if you click on that it will link
to something and then within here we're
going to have an image and first we'll
just do the source to the image and the
source will be using URL for like we had
before so let's just copy copy that
paste and this time that was located and
static but it was located in within
static it was located images slash in
the image is main logo dot PNG so that's
our image and our source so hopefully I
think that would be that's a fine thing
so we should be able to refresh that and
see the okay so sure enough there's our
image it's obviously way too big so we
need to size the image how do we do that
well we use another attribute called
style and now we add some style to this
bad boy so we're going to say the max
width is going to be 120 px for pixels
and then to give it a to give it a
little padding as it's called we use a
margin - top and that will be a negative
7 pixels actually and that should be
everything we need let's save and run
good okay so that looks pretty similar
to this one obviously it's slightly
different but that's ok
so a max well it's probably the max
width that's different on the other one
anyway well we'll worry about that later
anyway that's our header now let's say
we want to add the start learning button
how would we how would we do that well
first we want to have
let's go over here and let's do nav -
pills now and we can say see here that
these are like new pills that are added
to our navigation bars so we can take
that and it's still going to be actually
well we'll keep it I think if I want to
I think actually the way I've done it is
it's still within the header but not
within those so let me tab this over but
to keep our standards good fix our
spacing issue will come down and then
we'll take this code here copy that
paste and then we'll fix the indentation
by the way I guess I didn't really cover
but if you highlight a big block of text
and you hit tab that moves it over and
if you want to get it back over tab so
we can save that we'll come back over
here refresh and we can see there is at
least a nav bar it's a little too high
there we'll need to fix that but we can
and so now we basically want all this
stuff but the we don't really need any
of this stuff here and in fact we don't
even need it to be a list item at all
but we'll leave it there just to be we
might end up adding pills later so
that's why I had it there so that I'm
gonna go ahead and leave it so that's
what I've done on the main website as
well but anyway now we want to make a
button so how do we make a button let's
go back over to components control F I'm
sure we can find something for buttons
sure enough here are some button code so
let's highlight copy/paste let's fix the
oh dear Lord let's oh it's so hard for
me to see it - let me just make let's
make this full screen and in fact for
now okay so this is our button code it's
within this unordered list here so there
it is and I guess I'm not going to make
it fullscreen we'll save that let's come
back to our file here refresh and we see
right now the button is just this I
don't know
kind of some sort of bars but that's
okay it is a button off to a good start
so in um in bootstrap you have some
words that mean the same thing across
the board so default is generally like
this there's nothing in it it's no color
and then you've got things like oh well
for sure primary is like a dark blue
you've got like a info ward danger and
all this other stuff and they applied
two different colors but generally
you've got blue green yellow and red and
so you but you can look those all of
those up by always coming here so here
you've got red in its danger but then
you also have some that's like I think
it's called warning for like a red color
I'm trying to find one that's there
solid it's right here so here's some
solid blue and lots active links trying
to find colored I think I had just seen
some here we go right so you've got
primary four blue green is success info
this like cyan ish color warning danger
okay so you can use these different
colors so we'll use BTN four button
BTN - primary is the the other attribute
that it's going to have so now that
should be blue sure enough it is but at
the same time we could also say okay
instead of primary it's success save
that come over here now it's a green
button but we're going to make it
primary anyway primary save that and now
we have a button the button doesn't do
anything it also has a logo that we're
not interested in so we're actually
interested we want this button to look
like this
start learning okay so first of all
let's make the button actually say
something so this has a span on it and
span is for the glyph icon and then you
come over here and we can add start
learning save that and then let's say we
want a different glyph icon so we'll
come over here components is where the
glyph icons are go to the very very top
and the wording for it was actually off
I think but it looks like the power
symbol so I liked it
so do it will copy
that come over here and whoops I don't
know what that moved doesn't look like
it did anything serious but okay yeah so
glyph icon highlight that whoops
highlight all that paste good primary
good it doesn't link to anything yet but
we'll I'll show you that in just a
moment
save that refresh now we have a start
learning button
next let's make the button the right
size so we're going to use the style
well as I don't think it already has
style it does not so we'll add a style
equals and then in quotes we're going to
add a bunch of parameters here the first
style is going to be margin - top will
do 5 p 5px semicolon space margin -
bottom will be so margin - bottom : and
we're going to make this 5px semicolon
height : 44 PX semicolon and then
finally margin - right
15 let's don't forget your : 15px and
that's it for the button and then what
we'll do to actually make this button do
something as we encase the entire button
in this these a tags right for links so
a href equals and this button for us
heads to dashboard and then put the K
over here save come over here let's
refresh
there's our start learning button we'll
click on it it's going to return a 404
but well know it works
sure enough sends us to slash dashboard
no problem and that's that okay so I'm
going to cut off the tutorial here if
you guys are really familiar with HTML
and bootstrap I apologize but I did
definitely want to cover how we're doing
a lot of stuff anybody who this is all
foreign to would be I think really
confused I didn't want to just gloss
over it we still have a lot of kind of
basic HTML and CSS to cover but once
we're kind of done with this main page
will be
much more heavily in flasks and all that
but I did want this tutorial would be a
pretty holistic how to create a website
tutorial so I apologize if it's kind of
moving slow for some of you guys but I
think it's pretty necessary so anyways
that's it up to this point hopefully you
guys are enjoying if you do have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions
until next time